hello everyone and welcome back to
game review my name is caleb dunby and
today
i'm going to take you through a game by
the world champion
magnus carlson against his trash talking
rival anish geary
of course these two have been known to
get into it on twitter
over their various chess skills uh who
can forget
uh some infamous tweets by magnus
carlson such as
win a tournament for the first time in
your life and maybe then people will
take you seriously uh
with all of that backstory let's jump
into this game which was played actually
in the finals of the chesable masters
tournament
part of the magnus carlsen tour you know
named after the man himself
and in this game maggie bogues played
the move
1d4 we have knight f6 c4
e6 knight c3 bishop b4
arriving at the nimzo indian and i
believe this is the only time magnus
uh played into the nimzo indian in this
match
nowadays at the top level you do see
people trying to avoid the nimzo with a
move like knight f3 here
they have been opting for more standard
qgd setups lately
rather than go for the nimzo indian with
knight c3
and then magnus actually had a really
really interesting idea
now there's a ton of different ways
white can play against the nimzo there
is the
classical with queen c2 defending the
knight with the queen
there's e3 going for a more solid
approach in the center
there's knight f3 for the two knights
there is the f3 nemzo
my personal favorite bishop g5 for i
think the leningrad
but magnus plays a sideline a pretty
serious sideline with the move a3
and this is a move that just immediately
clarifies the situation on the queen's
side
forces black more or less to capture
this knight on c3
and i had always thought that this a3
line was just a little bit inaccurate
for white to be honest
the reason for that is that you get very
similar
positions out of the f3 nimso but with
f3 included
you make black sort of make one more
move make one more decision
before you go ahead and kick this bishop
away
so for example if a move like c5 you get
d5
and then all of a sudden this bishop
doesn't have the retreating square
and if d5 well then it's not so easy to
go for the dark square setups
that black can normally get with a3
immediately now the situation
is totally totally clarified and after
bishop takes c3
and b takes c3 uh black
has not yet committed to castling for
one and he has not yet committed
to any central breaks for two
and so the way that i had kind of been
told or
taught or learned over the years to play
against the a3 nimzo
is to quite simply go directly after
this
c pawn you can kind of contrast this
line
with the f3 nimso where black will
sometimes castle
a3 takes takes and now 98 is actually
the main move here
the point being the bishop pin is rather
awkward with the king
castled king's side the reason for that
being if you don't play this way and you
just go ahead with b6
suddenly it becomes rather awkward to
try to drive this bishop away
with things like h6 and g5 now you can
compare this line
with a3 immediately and followed by b6
now if white ever goes for this bishop
g5 business suddenly the move h6
and g5 is a very satisfying
way to sort of block this bishop out of
the game and so this i think
is kind of the most principled way to
play against the a3
nimzo indian with black the point being
you highlight the fact that white has
not made you castle
with the move order involving f3 and now
you have very simple play going against
the c
pawn with your minor pieces and playing
c5
opening the c file bringing a rook to
the c file
and play can continue very unnaturally
from there
for black now niche gear chooses a
different setup with
c5 and i think this is actually slightly
more common
but to be totally honest i think it
makes a little bit less sense
for black here the reason being you can
get sort of better positions
uh from the c5 business if you play
against the f3 line first so it sort of
makes sense to play the optimal version
of whatever you can in my opinion at
least that being said c5 is by no means
a bad move by nishikiri it's a perfectly
acceptable
opening line magnus continued with the
move e3
we had knight c6 increasing the pressure
to white's center
bishop d3 is the natural developing move
we have d6
and now magnus decides to develop this
knight
in this line this knight is not really
aiming for the
f3 square the reason being the setup
that black has adopted
is very much playing against this
knight's various hops
and so it comes to e2 instead also
notably if it lands
on f3 you have some concerns about a
potential e4 push later in the game
for black so 92 instead aiming for the
g3 square to control these squares a
little bit
more thoroughly black continues with the
move e5 which is very sensible
just challenging this center further and
then we have knight g3
by the world champion magnus carlson and
then
gary plays a move which i am actually
quite willing to call
a pretty serious mistake here uh in
some variations for example let me just
put something on the board here
you can imagine castles uh f3 for
example
let's say b6 castles and now the move h5
would be very very uh standard in this
position
the reason being this knight on g3 can
very easily be pushed away by the move
h4 and with white having castled and
played the move
f3 the move h4 in response doesn't make
a whole lot of sense
by white this pawn is just going to be
weak
and white does not actually have access
to the h5 pawn
himself and so you'll see h5 in
positions like this
and it makes a ton of sense here because
you're forcing this knight to do
something awkward like come back to h1
and back out to f2 now in this position
anish giri also played the move h5 but
here i do believe it makes a lot less
sense
the reason being these two moves for
white have not been included
f3 and castles not included here and
because of that the move h4
actually becomes quite a strong reply
for magnus carlsen
now this pawn is backed up by this rook
on
uh on h1 and after queen e7
magnus carlson makes a very very logical
decision here he needs this rook
on h1 to defend h4 which means this king
is going to be chilling in the center
for some time now so magnus immediately
makes an effort to close the center with
the move d5
and this is a very uh very nice idea by
magnus you know
he doesn't want to castle the king
anymore so he still works to make the
his king have a safe home and that safe
home is just going to be in the center
by locking it down and now anish makes
another pretty serious mistake here i
don't know if he realized how severe
uh his uh how severe the danger he was
facing here actually was
because after his move knight b8 uh
which
is fine if you're gonna move the knight
the issue is
that now magnus can get a a pretty
seriously winning advantage
with the move e4 anish
simply couldn't allow magnus to totally
lock down the center
in this manner after e4 white is just
dominating
in the center and dominating on the
king's side and very quickly anisha is
going to realize that this pawn
is simply indefensible so because of
that anish's really only move to
maintain the balance here
was to play e4 himself you have to take
this space
while you can then if d takes c6 e takes
d3
is doing totally fine for anish
with these pawns looking rather awkward
and if this
bishop simply moves back i don't know to
e2 for example now the move 95
comes on the board and this knight is is
sort of a monster
here on the e5 square and it is actually
black
who is going to be having a significant
advantage bishop b1
might try a little bit harder
highlighting that f95 we do get this
pawn
but it's sort of irrelevant to the
position because this knight is so
strong that black is more than willing
to give up his e pawn for it in fact the
c
pawn is going to die in almost every
variation here
so e4 would have been a nice find by
anish but after knight b8 e4 by magnus
locks down this idea and now the black
pieces simply have no room to breathe
the move bishop g4 was played and now
simply f3
by magnus not giving away this g4 square
and after bishop c8s this kind of really
highlights the dire situation of niche
gears minor pieces
none of them have any squares this
knight is looking at
nothing this bishop has no developing
moves
this knight can come to d7 and maybe b6
but
it doesn't do a whole lot there and it's
it's just pretty dire straights now
for a niche bishop g5 was magnus
carlson's move
uh developing his piece to or his final
minor piece to a good square
and now after queen c7 simply bishop
takes f6 and g
takes f6 notably if a move like knight b
to d7
uh simply knight f5 is is kind of the
issue
that's coming this is why queen c7
appears on the board just
to get this queen out of the way
preemptively
of knight five business so queen c7
takes takes
and now the pawn structure is bad for
anish as well
uh now with the f or the
diagonal closed with the pawn on f6
magnus is happy to castle as the rook is
no longer needed here
now knight d7 comes on the board and uh
white to move and get a serious
advantage here if you want to try to
find out at home
go ahead of course this move is f4
just breaking open the f file and once
again highlighting the weakness on h5
now that this bishop is temporarily
unable to get to g4
and this is the issue with just having
less space as a niche did in this game
your pieces start stepping
on each other's toes e takes f4
and now of course uh magnus could
capture on f4 but he wants the h5 pawn
instead
making sure that this bishop is not
landing on g4
knight e5 was the move by anish but now
knight takes f6
comes with check king d8 and rook takes
f4
is quite simply extra material for
magnus he is up two pawns here uh
no less and now uh knight to g6
was a niche gears move and once again
i'd like you guys at home to try and
find
magnus carlson's next move it's a pretty
instructive one
showing how to value your pieces in this
type of position
so go ahead pause at home if you want to
try to find it the move of course
is not to move this rook away because if
you move this rook away
anish giri is going to take on h4 and
honestly
this knight's coming back to e5 and
anish is in there sort of with with a
fighting chance you know he gets this h4
pawn back
and his pieces start to to spring to
life so
this h4 pawn is much more valuable than
an exchange in this case
so magnus in in an attempt to keep this
material plays the move queen f3
just defending the the rook and now if
rick takes h4
this is pretty much unplayable because
at the end of the day this queen is
invading
for example here the killer move e5 and
knight takes c5 means
queen hha check and black is sort of
just getting checkmated here in
short order even rookie one
and all the pieces are surrounding the
black king this bishop can't move
because of this
rook and it's it's just sort of
devastating
so rook takes h4 prevented by the move
queen f3
but of course anish could capture this
rook instead though he plays the move
queen e7
not yet capturing and after h5 now
forcing black's hand we do see
knight takes f4 and queen takes f4
anish now tries to trade down a little
bit to ease his
spatial woes with queen e5 we have queen
takes e5
d takes e5 and the move g4 is very
natural
and magnus's compensation for the pawn
for the exchange
is these two killer past pawns on the
king's side
uh a5 was geary's choice trying to find
some way to get this rick active
we see g5 by the world champion rook a6
now
getting active with this rook and then
magnus actually makes a
a pretty serious mistake oops and now
magnus actually makes a pretty serious
mistake
uh oh my gosh i ruined everything danny
and so after rook a6 the world champion
actually makes a pretty serious mistake
here
uh it's an interesting mistake for him
to make considering
how in the previous position he was so
ready to give up the exchange in order
to maintain these pawns that
he seems to have not considered black
doing the same thing giving up the
exchange to remove these pawns
so by far i think the best move here for
magnus is to play the move bishop e2
and the point of this move is it over
defends the h5 pawn and this is relevant
because now the move rook takes f6
is not going to be any good for black
this h5 pawn
stays on the board and now without the
extra exchange
he really has nothing for it now you can
compare that with the move played in the
game
rook b1 eyeing to stop the rook b6 idea
but now after rook takes f6 and g takes
f6 we have rook takes h5
and all of a sudden black is very much
in this game with a very active rook
and with the threat of the past pawns
being eliminated
uh and this really does throw away
almost magnus's
entire advantage here much much better
was to play the move bishop e2
when black now of course wouldn't
sacrifice the exchange and he does get
the move
rook b6 in but it's not totally relevant
right we play the move king f2
we get our king in the game and you can
imagine very very quickly
rook g1 g6 g7 g8
and then the game is just going to be
over uh so it's an interesting mistake
for
magnus to to make here allowing his
opponent
to sacrifice the material back in order
to get a fighting chance in this end
game
but we do see rook b1 and immediately
snaps
on f6 we have gf6 rook takes h5
and now rook b5 magnus getting active
himself but he sort of has to win this
game
all over again rook h3 is now
challenging
the pawns from behind we have bishop e2
rook takes c3 rook a5
this rook now hops over to the e3 square
with
a fork we have bishop h5 a pretty clever
move by the world champion
going for the more relevant pawn on f7
rather than worry about trying to save
these pawns
in the center and on the queen side and
actually this is probably a mistake by
anish going after e4
when instead the really only relevant
pawn in this position
for the moment is this pawn on f6
because of that
the much better maneuver for anish was
to play the move rook
g3 check king f2 and then come up to g6
just ensuring this f pawn is going
nowhere fast
uh getting this guy off the board and
then sort of remaneuvering recouping in
this end game
notably he's gonna keep at least three
pawns and so he might end up down a pawn
with some scary pawns in the center for
example rook takes c5 or it takes f6
king e3 for example but now after a move
like rook a6
black is is definitely very much not
not doing poorly in in this case so
anish missed an opportunity here to pick
up the f6
pawn after rookie three white is back in
the driver's seat with this nice move
bishop h5
uh f7 is just too important rook takes
c4 by anish and now
rook a8 is the very very clever move
by magnus carlson notably if bishop
takes f7
you're falling for a little bit of a
rook g4 trick
if you go this way we have rook h4 and
eventually
you're going to have to step to the f
file otherwise there's a repetition
and the moment that you do we do see the
move rook
f4 check with a capture on f6 to follow
of course you can't go to h3 because
of well not that move but rick g6 check
would pick up this pawn
as well so
uh not bishop takes f7 as i said
guarding the g4 square instead and now
we do see the move
rook to a8 pinning this bishop king c7
is black's attempt to unpin but
unfortunately now the story is a little
bit different we do see the move
bishop takes f no not bishop takes f7
rather
but there is another key idea here
notably the only reason this repetition
works
is because this bishop is defending
these squares so
magnus finds a way to make sure that
bishop doesn't defend those squares if
you want to try to find it yourself at
home
go ahead and pause here if not the
answer of course
is this nice move d6 check of course if
king takes d6 you're running into rook
takes c8
so king d7 instead but this is the go
ahead now
because this bishop is no longer
guarding these squares
magnus can now take on f7 we have rook
g4 check
and the king just walks up the board not
even rook h4 check
when king g3 would leave black with no
checks rather
we do see the movie rook f4 king g3
and now rook takes f6 does come on the
board but as i said a very
different story here with these pieces
so awkwardly placed
the move bishop h5 is just devastating
here
there's simply no way to untangle these
pieces and
prevent white from simply capturing on
c8 in the coming moves
uh for example if you play king d8
trying to step out of the check
we'll still bishop g4 and this bishop is
pence
you cannot remove this king anyway
otherwise rook takes c8 you cannot even
try to defend the bishop with rook f8
because bishop g4 check still
makes the king move away or block off
the rook
and so anish geary here simply losing a
piece and with it the game we have
bishop g4 check bishop takes c8s
and now magnus picks up on b7 as well
and it's just a matter of time for
corralling these
pawns in the center for magnus getting
his king back
and now after a4 and rook takes c5
we say we see bishop c2 and with
all of the pieces for white coordinated
this pawn is dropping and this pawn is
promoting anish geary simply resigns
here
so a very nice game by the world
champion
uh with two very interesting exchange
sacrifices
being featured uh definitely an
interesting opening debate
and i do think anish will live to regret
playing this move h5
so early on in the opening this is what
gave magnus the advantage in my opinion
well thank you very much for joining me
on this episode of game review
my name is caleb denby and i will see
you next time